لا يفارق جواره وبالملابس العسكريه
الخضراء نفسها يظهر ذراع زيلينسكي اليمنى
بشكل دائم خلف الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي
وحامل سابق ومنتج سينمائي يبلغ من العمر
واحد وخمسين عاما يعمل منذ عام 2020 ككبير
موظفي رئيس الاوكراني لكن وظيفه الحقيقيه
تتخطى المسمى الوظيفي فهو يملك صلاحيات
الرئيس الثاني في اوكرانيا وفق صحيفه وولز
ضد الدبلوماسيه الرسميه التي ماتت وفق
تعبيره ويعتقد ان الوقت ضروري الان للقوه
الناعمه وبالتالي النتائج العلاقه
المباشره للبيت الابيض مع اوكرانيا تمر به
اندرويد فهو يجري مكالمات منتظمه مع
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سولفن
او رجل بايدن الحرب ثقه زيلينسكي عمياء
بكبير موظفيه فهو يمكن اليه كل الوظائف
الهامه بينها الضغط
لمزيد من شحنات الاسلحه والاشراف على
تبادل الاسرى مع موسكو كما ان حمله
العلاقات العامه التي احتاجتها كييف في
الغرب سيرها رجلا اوكرانيا معا مستفيدين
من مواهبهما في العمل التلفزيوني لمخاطبه
الشعوب الغربيه علم البيان ماك احد
الرافدين لمفاوضات حاليا مع روسيا بينما
لا تزال قوتها على الاراضي الاوكرانيه حسب
قولها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات